I'm cool.
You're cool?
Yeah.
What am I?
I don't know.
Not cool?
Yeah, I'm not cool.
Wow.
Within five seconds she broke it.
Okay everybody, happy weekend.
Welcome to another mail time.
We've got some packages here that we're going to open.
Nina decided to wear her sunglasses today.
Because it's nice and sunny out today.
This is the shaking ahead.
It's the shaking ahead.
Okay, well, we've got a couple of packages.
If you want to send us something that we will open up on the next mail time, we'll leave
the address below and send it to Charlie and Salsa.
First up, we've got a package from Happy Worker.
Whoa.
What is in the package?
Next up, Schmoyer Media.
You broke it?
Are you serious?
Age is 15 plus.
I'll glue it back.
You broke it?
Are you serious?
I thought you can move it up.
I thought the arm could move.
Oh my God.
Within five seconds she broke it.
All right, Happy Worker.
We may need another one because Nina can't be tried.
It should say on the packaging.
Not meant for Nina's.
Nina's extra care.
Holy cow.
Okay, next up.
What was this?
Oh, Schmoyer Media.
I can now battle Kylo Ren with my Video Creators TV shirt.
Okay, next up.
Will Martin.
Oh, books.
Books.
Hold on.
We got this book.
See what it is?
This is from Ryan Holiday.
Ryan Holiday is an author and somebody reached out to him recently.
They sent me a trio of books.
Trust me, I'm lying.
The obstacle is the way.
Growth Hacker Marketing.
Thank you, Ryan.
Much appreciated.
Okay, last but not least.
The big package.
Kylo Ren is this big and the box is this big.
Wow.
This is from NRI Distribution.
Congratulations.
You're one of the first people to receive an Overstand.
Stand up desk.
Let's do it.
Let's see it.
Let's build one.
I said it.
Oh, this part's pretty easy, but then I don't want to break it.
Then push this in.
Oh, down like that.
And then how does it walk?
I don't know.
So the idea here is you turn any surface into a stand-up desk.
Instead of sitting down, you can stand up just for a piece of carpet.
Try it, Nina.
I think it's good, Nina.
Right?
It's not my height right now.
This height goes to the top.
Okay.
Push it down.
And there's Nina.
Nina now has a stand-up desk.
Alright.
Cool.
I like that.
So we've got a package of five of these things.
We've got to get them away.
So thank you guys for the stuff.
Thank you for joining us for another video of Mail Time.
If you want to send me something, I'll open it on the next edition.
The address to Toronto Land Salsa is in the description.
I appreciate it.
Have an amazing weekend.
Continue to believe.
And I'll see you soon.
Alright.
Bye, guys.
Bye.